the coronavirus is taking a
serious toll on doctors and nurses
mental health as america's death toll
approaches 200 thousand
the largest study of front-line medical
workers at the height of the pandemic in
new york city found
57 percent of them had acute stress
48 percent saw depressive symptoms and
nearly 75 percent
experienced insomnia senior medical
correspondent dr taran narula spoke with
doctors and nurses in new york city
also new mexico and florida about the
stress they face
you train expecting that someday there
may be a catastrophe but living it
is something i don't think you ever
fully are
prepared for we may walk into the
building
take care of our patients do what we
have to do but on the inside
you know we're suffering we just went
from
one patient to another without having
any time
and between to process what just
happened it's made me almost rethink
my career choice rethink what it is to
be a nurse
describe for me the toll that this is
taken on you
emotionally and mentally i don't
honestly know if i've been this tired in
my life
we're all tired emotionally
intellectually
spiritually i meet criteria from mild
depression
there are emotional places in my icu i
don't like going past
because of cases i remember i'm a 24
year old with children who died from a
stroke
a 25 year old man who died with his
parent and his wife at his bedside
still hurt i have like
terrible insomnia i experience
nightmares
i close my eyes and i see the patient
that i took care of last
i see the images of suffering and i
think that's going to scar me for life
nightmares about like my previous
assignment like did i do everything that
i need to do
i feel like the anxiety is kind of just
following me into sleep and so i'm not
getting adequate rest you tried to fall
asleep but my mind was
completely replaying what i went through
throughout the day would i really have
to decide
who lives and who dies i think
surprisingly
we found that about over 50 percent of
individuals
had acute stress disorder which may
develop actually in post-traumatic
stress disorder we also found that
nearly half of our participants
developed depressive symptoms i'm not
going to leave tomorrow will i bring
this home to my family
what am i going to do just questions
questions
questions having to kind of
absorb what family members would usually
absorb where they're at the end of life
and so now we're we're absorbing that
grief in those moments and maybe
multiple times in a shift
so that's difficult do you worry about
ptsd
a lot for the most part i may be
exhibiting
slight symptoms of ptsd i can feel a
difference in my personality
because i'm usually a bubbly person and
i think i've lost that
my fuse is shorter i'm more irritable
i think i'm just afraid it's like being
a rope where you just twist and you
twist and eventually
you fray why do you think it's so
difficult for
health care workers and medical
professionals to talk about
issues around mental health like
depression anxiety
fear we're kind of expected to just
suck it up to compartmentalize
everything we see
we feel as though we won't be valued in
our profession if we
speak on what we live with on our daily
lives and what's kind of part of us
the white coat makes a great straight
jacket that we don't
talk about the things we need to and
that needs to stop
right now in coba the idea of being the
healthcare hero
really adds this increased burden on
individuals
when you see these billboards of
healthcare heroes and our heroes wear
scrubs and so on and so forth
and you look at yourself and you realize
i'm no hero
i'm broken i'm hurting it's just another
point of
self-critique that i am supposed to be
this hero now
and i'm not and it's another point of
pain
we're seen as resilient that we're
unbreakable
and if we don't address what we have
going on internally it's really
difficult to adequately care for
our patients covet 19 has provided us an
ability to talk about our own
vulnerabilities and to say
that's okay because from vulnerability
actually that's the birthplace for
courage
it's a birthplace of joy and i think
it's really really important
to be okay with that
and our doctor tara narula joins us now
dr nerol that is a
very powerful story you could hear it in
those people's voices what they were
going through uh the complicated
reaction to being called a hero
all the stress that they bear what can
we as patients as the public do
to help uh workers who are struggling
with their mental health
yeah i know tony i'm emotional just
watching it back but you know i think
the first step is really
normalizing this and that's what
everybody said we need to begin to talk
about this
openly family and friends and co-workers
should know they can ask
their friends how are you doing how are
you feeling and not just
ask but really listen institutions and
hospital systems need to build in
support and also
create a culture where it's okay to talk
openly where you don't feel you'll be
looked down upon
but one of the ironies of this is that
it's really our emotions
our vulnerability as healthcare
providers that make us the best healers
and
dr abdallah said very very well when you
start to lose that
we start to lose the ability to connect
to someone who's suffering that's when
it's time to actually leave
the healthcare profession yeah that's
definitely true very powerful story dr
taran rula thank you very much